ich feiere so hallo nahezu nächsten
folge von minecraft galaxy impreza mit
demokratischen hallo diesmal eigentlich
zutritt ja weil ich habe ja noch hier
meine kleine kiste die luftführung und
sammeln einfach alles ein
es ist wunderschön ich bin auch
eigentlich ja ich bin ganz allein ich
bin eine kleine fehler muss ich hab
keinen freund bevor ich wollte mir
einfach das wollte sich dennoch fragen
hast du ja aber die sind blöd das
einzige was ich sagen kann dass haye
master und damit den kann ich mich
unterhalten
du kannst bei der kiste ein
wunderschönes gespräch bestimmt anfangen
nein denn ich nicht sie läuft auf eine
ruhefrist alles auf dann können sie
wenigstens fressen eine können nicht wir
können nur an dauert ist vielleicht
könnte man sagen muss dass man in meinem
haus gerade ich gehe hier um hat mir
gerade eine diamant hose gemacht
schlicht fliegt man wolle jetzt meine
sachen sortieren danach wollte ich eine
aktiv liegt die auch hinterher
die teleportieren daher das so wirklich
dachten die fliegen jetzt zu aldi oder
erreicht mensch nicht nach plan machen
wir noch eine diamant pigs glaub ich hab
keine ich hab kraftfahrers eingesammelt
hier max noch anderen ananas ging gerade
das kannst haben heißt ein apple weiß
englisch ist aber ja ich habe auch das
kann ich dir so essen ja gibt noch mal
dazu du kannst den anderen das feld
anliegen einfach auf den boden setzen
genauso nacht und kristi chester wo bist
du
kriszti kiss is a look back herum
der kleine scheiße wer ich nein meine
kinder hier hallo meine kiste
sie musste eigentlich nur ganz kurz und
wohl wasser damit ich mir so fällt hier
bauen kann
ich habe die kiste verloren ich glaub
ich muss ein ganzes haus mal irgendwie
doch ich sage mal kurz ein und bringt
man kurz hochtief habe ich probleme ich
bin sofort wieder oben
ich bin zum auf dem weg nach oben
ich muss mein ganzes haus mal sortieren
also an alle die hier gerade bei mir
gucken hier vorne soll ja meine glaswand
hin
also du kannst es wahrscheinlich auch
sehen hier vorn habe ich gerade bin soll
meine glaswand hin klar damit ich halt
deine scheiss kiste ich will auch
shooting leistungsorientiert sogar beide
natürlicher die beine christi das aus
oder kann anders gegessen
ich mag deine kiste nicht richtig boxen
oder so ich warte ich mache jetzt angst
ich dachte schon die hat mich
angegriffen alter nichts hinterher
gelaufen das ritter gefallen ach egal
lustig denn ich bin ja hallo ich habe
eine katze auf dem kopf den karton kommt
jack russel wirklich wieder einen sehr
einsam auf ziel ist es richtig gut
ich nehme jetzt mal eben meine normale
form wieder an
also jetzt mal ganz kurz ich möchte dass
ich quasi hier so ein glas dings mache
dass ich quasi hier so schön gucken kann
weil genau da hinten geht die sonne
unter dass es wunderschön so abends und
dann mache ich hier irgendwie noch so
einfältig machte verschiedene räume und
hier soll dann glaube ich so meinen ja
hier kommen entfällt irgendwie hin und
dann mache ich das hier jetzt einfach
mal voll mit wasser dann kommt hier so
zu sagen konnte was aber das passt sogar
alles was ich hier damals schon will so
hingelegt habe ach mensch eigentlich
wollte ich eine wüste suchen aber weiß
das ist halt nicht einfach so einfach
wahllos ziel das sollte ale arbeit
wahrscheinlich gibt es gar keiner noch
2000 andere sachen als kann mich erzählt
so hab ich mal
ich brauche nur dass athen bei den
farbstoff wenn es dir nicht irgendwo
anders herkriegen könnte also es war ja
durch einen pastis ist es ja möglich daß
man wolle bekommt wenn wir dadurch
irgendwie farbstoff kriegen würde das
auch super klasse aber irgendwie weisen
kaluga läuft gerade irgendwie alles
nicht so toll hier
organspenden ja klar körper machen ich
lieg schon drin so schön ich habe uns in
badehose scannern ja ich hab mir sommers
hin gemacht wird bei mir vielleicht
nicht so gut aussehe wenn ich mit zum
anzug und der badehose wäre vielleicht
witzig aber mit zum anzug und badehose
weiß nicht wer blickst du schon im bett
ja ich schon drin
okay gut ich backe gar die ganze dass
mein bett raus aber ich glaube dass
musste trotzdem funktionieren wenn jetzt
nicht es gibt doch nicht ich denke ich
mal ganz kurz noch mal rein war für mich
schon wieder raus ich bin noch gar nicht
verwandeln was hatten der wird noch
konkreter
jetzt geht's ich muss mich irgendwie
noch mal von crafter zu contra
verwandeln so ich packe jetzt hier
einfach wasser fallen dann noch jemand
fällt was machst du jetzt
ich mach dir gleich mal ein geschenk
weil ich hätte nach hause lustiges wort
richtig gut zu deiner bude passen würde
ich habe ich mir gesagt ich erreiche in
diesem projekt alleine was aber wenn du
eingeschränkt rené das hätte längst hat
es ja nicht so oma sagte sind einander
sei du dich mich sehr darüber freuen
es ist ja abate macht ihm hatte ich
würdige dass das könnte gehen
warte warte ich gucke ob das geht wenn
das geht ich dachte mich so weg okay
wenn ich witzig wenn es was zu tun hat
ich hoffe dass jetzt geht muss man ganz
viel ich weiss also nächsten folgenden
verlieren bisschen produktiver seien am
samstag war ich noch mal live stream
machen und dann soll das auch flüssig
genug ich begreife ich davon beim
kontakt wenn du eines tages wegen stirbt
irgendwann der tag irgendwann wird der
moment kommen
aber man soll jetzt bin ich wieder der
film außer ich wollte mich das ganze ein
bisschen schöner machen von außen die
ganze fassade blöde stein mal ganz groß
auf ob das geht
so jetzt kommt dann einen fällt hin und
kommt da so eine trennwand hin
das thema auch im ganz schnell zu ihr ab
ich komme gerade mal zu dir
ich feiere das jetzt so hat du wirst
lachen wenn du das nicht machen
warte ich gespannt was du jetzt gehst
meist sich weg oder ich hoffe sie
wegschmeißen oftmals trifft den hunger
wenn du zufällig noch gut finde ich gar
nicht vergessen ein farb alle da hast du
brauchst glaube ich ein lapislazuli eine
rote wolle und grüne wollen aber so
stimmt ja eh nicht weil du brauchst das
cactus zurück da kann man nicht das auch
noch färben
aber egal ich mache jetzt nur kratzen
befinden
ich sehe schon dass fragezeichen im kopf
stehen wahrscheinlich ich stehe hier
galt als schaf und guckt einfach in eine
richtung ich komme da raus kommt ich bin
gleich da ich sehe dich dann werde ich
auch das wird jetzt richtig neu passau
das von lpkf so hart zu feiern
achtung und zwar manchmal ganz kurz hier
das da sie ja schöne position erfordert
manchmal jetzt dass da hier mach mal
kürzt das daher hatte ich mache ganz
kurzen moment ich mal ganz gut nicht als
lebensmittel ist ich hab noch nicht
angekommen ich muss mir von vorn
angucken kürze was das war
kann man den abbauen und ein bisschen
weiter nach vorne setzen
ich kann ja klar ich kann ja eine neue
machen hier
wie macht man sich da eine neue gibt
dann schöne zeiten bevor du musst du so
ein hammer machen wenn man mal starte
und lachen dann nicht auch mal kurz die
hinterrad ich kann der kontakt zu medien
gegeben dass ich dem inventar hat weil
dann würde ich mir so eine plattform
hier vormachen sowie welt so titanic
weiß wo der leisen das reicht schon zwei
sticks und 2 sind macht ja das hat das
ist alles nicht wertvoll aber man muss
halt darauf kommen dass man so was macht
farbstoff gab es hier noch einfärben
können jetzt ihr dann original skin der
auch ein gefährt ist wenn mit ihr zwei
analysen wo muss ich dann die 2000 in
park und die 26 du machst diagonal unten
also ganz unten links und in die mitte
machst du den stick und den den oben
mittleren und den rechten mittleren
machst du dann die eisen rein links und
mitte unten stick und mitte mitte und
rechtsmittel ein
wenn das geht steht da kommt dann heraus
dass man hier in den crafting station
rein
die ich in der nähe ein gestellter also
warte so hast du es gesagt so ach so ja
okay gut so haben wir jetzt halt zwei
blöcke macht egal welche und dann wird
man kurz kanzlerin zeigen wenn hinten
bist dann kannst du nicht dass da machen
randomized random eiskalter da bin ich
klar einfach dreimal im land
lehrer nehmen sofort fische dance parade
fahren kann ich da einfach in einen
namen eingeben
wie gesagt wenn diese farbpalette dass
kanzler einfärben
lewis hat er ganze armee von sich in
seinem schrank schildauer skulpturen
ich wollte halt krank machen ob es geht
nicht krank gemacht hast verschieben
muss großen kleinschreibung beachten
ich hab doch richtig geschrieben wobei
hier ganz links habe ich auch schon
kranke mortier links ja die richter noch
mal an klicks das selber machen wurst
geht das hier einfach auf erde man kann
doch fast alles machen
na geht doch hier tanzt wie sie kinder
unterhält
guck mal dieses diese statue da dieser
krank da steht ein horn und guck mal die
rechts daneben das einfach nur eins
tiefsten nein bei der rechts ein leben
ist auch grund bei mir ehrlich bei mir
ins tiefste einschnitt pk drauf ach so
ja gut dann ist das bei mir nur kurzen
fehler ja aber so lustig unterscheidet
ist voll alter ist das stark ihr habt ja
gesagt lasst mich wie eine statue war
damit beschäftigen wie jetzt die ganze
zeit aber ich war die ganze andere kacke
erstmal ab hatte ich stelle mir anpassen
wer wenn du rechtsklick drauf machst
kannst du auch die buttons verschiedene
positionen von armen und beinen zu
ändern aber das hier vorne einfach zu
passen einfach erforderlich
damit sah sich veranlasst dann einfach
bei dem so ins inventar landwirtschaft
alles ein ding aber die lässt die ananas
lass dir aber richtig setzte
wahrscheinlich nur um ein bisschen
weiter nach vorne
willst du machen alltag rast ich glaube
ich stell mir einfach hier so ein paar
leute rein die ich einfach so bewundere
weil sie nicht als sie machen machst du
in hall of fame ja genau
dann machte mir davon noch im rohbau ich
muss mir ein schild machen ich mache
jetzt wie megaprojekten schild mit allzu
vielen sachen die ich noch machen möchte
das ist das coole hier daran dass ich
einfach das ist so durch ganzen lot so
viele sachen die man noch machen kann
gibt also viele bautechnisch meinte
kanzler blöcke mit einem hammer
eindrücken dass sie praktisch
flacher werden also wenn du so eine
delle boden habe es gilt von helmers
mama dropped youtube ist der bodenheimer
so eine belize aber nicht mit diesem
hammer nur wenigen die es dann wieder
ein anderer
der ist jetzt aber nur zum skypen also
recht gut gemacht ich habe ein brocken
entfernen können wir wenig aussetzen
das ist glaube ich einfach nur so zum
ich glaube dass asse bekommen weil du
das fossil zerbrochen ist ich habe ein
bio fossil sodass noch mit drin das noch
drin so dass man essen strawberry sieht
da werde ich demnächst voll wenn ich mal
anfangen hier so ein bisschen hier weiß
bescheid wisst ihr ich mag halt nur
gerade mein haus und nimmt dem ich
einfach nur das kulturen herum stellen
denn ich glaube ich mache mir einfach so
ich kaufe mir dass wir so cool wenn ich
mir dann bei craft account kaufen würde
und den nenne ich dann irgendwie
türsteher dann mache ich einfach ganz
viele türsteher und dann haben diese
böse skins an das einfach so witzig aber
da müsst ihr wieder zehn euro für so
einen schwarzen tag ausgeben für so eine
schwachsinns idee für den job ist fast
wert aber habe ich auch gedacht aber
irgendwie ich glaube ich mache auch egal
mal gucken aber dann haben nachher alle
sind türsteher davor stehen
ok wurde setzt hier erst mal ein ganzes
meine ganze ich habe gar keine erde mit
blödmann
aber meine minions haben erde und die
sind auch fertig das ist sehr sehr schön
muss man bei anfange profis zu hören
furchtbar ich nix machen klar ein
bisschen vorstellen ich hoffe mal das
ministerium dass du weißt auf jeden fall
schon mehr als ich aber ich mach jetzt
geraten ich hab ich mein gesetz wirklich
informiert über das meiste ja das wollte
ich eigentlich auch machen aber der weg
bisher noch nicht dazu gekommen ich
hatte ab jetzt bist halt irgendwann
zahlt dann mache ich das einfach mal
denke ich er selbst beziehe mich dahin
familie mich über jeden mord und dann
sollten wir auch niemand sagen später
abflug
du brauchst allianz elternhaus bei den
modellen sieht man schon dass und das
bei mir ist einfach so eine statue mit 2
1 in der hand
ach man dass wir zum dauer geld nicht
sichern kann wird so witzig dass ich
doch jetzt dass durch das ist falsch
gemacht
auch ich mache das wasser einfach zwei
lang und nicht so lustig machen
jetzt starb die medien spinnrad mal
wieder ein bisschen rum bei dir oder
beim wichtig wie macht man zusammen ich
beschwöre weg war unsichtbar wiederwahl
deshalb ja wenn es erstmal weg gemacht
jede menge eisen sammeln diesen das
sammeln ich wollte was vielleicht am
anfang vielleicht noch genauer spawnen
nicht mehr drüber wir freuen uns schon
wieder fertig nebels um getrocknet sind
dumm gewesen so warte hier in mitte ich
mache noch eben hier in der mitte zum
wasser streifen danach können wir direkt
verenden
also ich hab jetzt wirklich wieder an
fast nichts geschafft ich hab das doch
also ich hab jetzt in den drei folgen
also ihr müsst das ja wieder so als
session nehmen ihr seht ihr grab nur die
folge der folge haben wir echt wenig
geschafft aber gern gelacht und aber
davor wie ich das geschafft mit den
minions endlich und das letztendlich das
war nur acht level und ich hab diesen
skilled trick von diesem mit den
skulpturen hier gelernt das ist super
und ich glaub ich macht das echt mit
diesem türsteher oder wenn ihren account
habt der türsteher heißt dann oder wenn
ihren coolen account habt ihr einfach in
so ein böses kind hat dann schreibt in
euren namen dann schaue ich mir das
einfach mal an wieder heißt und sonst
würde ich sagen ich beende das ganze
tier an die letzten folgen schon immer
so ein bisschen überzogen sind es genau
bei 15 minuten
deswegen gehe ich jetzt vom server
herunter es war sehr sehr gut und wenn
es euch gefallen hat zeigt dass mit
einer bewertung und natürlich sagen sie
muss in der nächsten folge wieder von
michael stanke schon fürs zuschauen